This morning, a former
Republican candidate in New Mexico
is under arrest and facing charges
in connection with a series of shootings
targeting the homes of local
Democratic elected officials.
Solomon
Pena is an election
denying Trump
supporting a Republican
who did not concede his state Ho
even though he lost in a landsli
in November.
And police
say that he paid
other people to carry out for sh
We're also taking
part in the last one himself
This type of radicalism
is a threat to our nation
and it has made
its way to our doorstep
right here in Albuquerque, New M
But I know here we are going to
and we will not allow this
to cross the threshold
fundamentally at the end of the
This was about a right wing radi
an election denier who was arres
in someone who did the worst
imaginable thing you can do
when you have a political disagr
which is turn that to violence
that should never be the case.
The attacks on two
state legislators
and two county commissioners
began in December
after Pena
showed up to their homes
to protest his November election
The first shooting happened
on December 4th
at the Bernalillo
County Commissioner,
Adrian Balboa's home.
She's joining us now.
Good morning and thank you for
for being here.
I can't even imagine
what you're feeling as you're
you're seeing the developments
of what happened here.
But I guess my first question is
do you believe that this was mot
by the fact that he was upset ov
losing his election?
Yeah, I believe,
you know,
when some when it happens, I'm
still shocked.
You know,
when it happened, I knew that it
you know, that's
what we see
most pressing
with people
being aggressive around
denying the elections.
So I feel like, yes,
I feel like it was due to
really larger press people
thinking that, you know,
that this is possible, that this
Our elected officials
are putting violence
and we're in a position like thi
And he actually showed up at you
after he lost his election.
When was that?
And what did he say to you?
Yeah, he came to my house
after the election,
and he is an election denier.
He weaponized those dangerous th
to threaten me
and others, causing serious trau
Yes, he was saying that the elec
were fake, but
really speaking erratically.
I didn't feel threatened at the
but I did feel like he was,
you know, erratic.
Do you do you feel safe now?
Do you feel safer
now that he's been arrested?
I feel grateful
that he's not out there
to attack or target
any other anyone else.
You know, I am still shocked.
You know,
in New Mexico,
we have actual access
to our elected officials.
And so I'm relieved to hear that
people won't be targeted in this
by him. Any longer.
I want to share with our viewers
what you said in his statement
after he was arrested.
You said Totalmente
Pena is an election denier.
He weaponize those dangerous tho
to threaten me
and others, causing serious trau
We said politicians
at the highest levels of our gov
continue to make threats and vio
a regular part of the public dis
It has real impacts on our democ
and our lives.
What does all of this
say to you
about political extremism
in the United States?
You know,
when politicians at our highest
of government
continue
to make threats and violence
the regular part of public disco
it has real impacts on our democ
and our real lives.
I was shocked, came through my h
right where I had just hours bef
been playing with my granddaught
And you were saying that you're
your daughter doesn't feel safe
bringing your granddaughter over
since that
Yeah, I just you know, it's been
to be a brand new grandma and
my daughter,
that's such a great job
bringing her over.
And for the last month
and a half, hasn't because of th
Right.
Well, Commissioner,
we're sorry
that you had to go through this.
And this is even something
that we're having a conversation
but we're really glad that you c
to share your experience with us
Commissioner Adrian Balboa. Than
Thank you.
Too many of us experience this.
We must change it.
Yeah. Thank you so much.